[Musique]
l'intelligence artificielle et le
numérique font partie intégrante de nos
vies
ce sont 17 heures d'avenir
[Musique]
nous ne pouvons pas l'imaginer une
révolution sans le numérique
certes nous accusons un certain retard
c'est pourquoi la france et l'union
européenne doivent investir et soutenir
massivement nos entreprises et nos
startups pour ne pas qu'on se laisse
dominer par une concurrence d'autant
plus omniprésente et de plus en plus
féroce de la part de la chine et des usa
[Musique]
les républicains ont des réponses
concrètes pour l'europe de demain c'est
pour cela que je vote aurait et l'air
aux prochaines élections européennes le
26 mai prochain
[Musique]